welcome to exploring computing
today's video is linking web pages
part 1 making links so this is going to
be the first in a series of videos where
we're
going to take a look at different
aspects of creating web pages
combining both the html and the
cascading style sheets
and of course one of the things that
makes the web really interesting
is the fact that we can link one web
page to another web page remember that's
one of the key part
parts of hypertext markup and language
the hypertext component so we're going
to go ahead and start off with that
now we have already talked a little bit
about how to make links between web
pages but it's going to turn out that
there's a lot more to it
both strictly on the html side and also
when combining it with cascading style
sheets
so let's go ahead and get started so
here i've got a diagram representing
that
we've got a computer www.stanford.edu
and it has a bunch of files in it and
we're going to assume that these files
are all in the same folder and that they
are in the
top level directory for whatever
www.stanford.edu is using to serve up
web pages and i'll talk a little bit
more detail about
uh how that works a little bit later but
for now just uh
we're trying to keep things simple so
we've got these two files
and they are in the main location where
the www.stanford.edu server is going to
be serving up files
so i've got a laptop i'm going to go
ahead and visit and
i'm going to have the example.html file
sent to me
and so remember what we're looking at
here is how to create
links between pages so what we're going
to take a look at is
let's say uh i'm i'm currently viewing
the web page
associated with the example.html file
that has been downloaded on my laptop
and now um that web page example.html
has a reference to another webpage
and it's got a reference to the
another.html webpage
and so this is what the link might look
like and we've seen this before
so um you know this says oh i've got a
hypertext transfer protocol request
for the web server www.stanford.edu
and i want to get to the file
another.html
and then the text another web page which
is between the a start and the a n tag
that's text that's going to be linked
we'll talk a little bit later about
what it's going to look like and how we
might change the appearance
okay turns out that we can actually
shorten this and instead of saying
www.stanford.edu
another.html we can just say
another.html
and this is what it's referred to as a
relative reference
what we had before where we had the full
thing including the web
server and the protocol http that's what
we refer to as an absolute reference you
have this
choice when you're linking from one web
page to another web page
you need to decide am i going to use an
absolute reference
with the full http and the server or are
you going to have a relative reference
for you just have the name of the file
and the assumption with a relative
reference is that
that file that you are referring to
because remember this is a reference to
another.html from the file
example.html which currently is residing
with a copy both on the server and a
copy that has been sent to my laptop
the assumption is that i am referring to
another.html file that is
on the same server as the example.html
file that i'm currently looking at
and it's also in the same folder
now it is possible to have
different folders so if i am viewing
example.html and on the server it's
located
in a directory or folder that has a
second folder or directory
folder and directory are synonymous
and that folder's name is articles and
the articles
folder has a file called another.html on
it
then you can see i can use this relative
reference here so i can say articles
slash another.html so the article
slash with the slash immediately after
it indicates that that's a director or
folder
i should mention that there are
operating systems that use
other delimiters to indicate folders so
for example windows most notably uses
the backslash
the macintosh used to use colons before
they got to os x and switched over to
underlying
operating system being unix
but regardless of what the underlying
operating system of either
the the client the web client meaning my
laptop or the web server
meaning www.stanford.edu regardless of
the operating system for either of those
when we're talking about web stuff we're
always going to use that
standard slash okay so
um so i'm going to go ahead and say hey
you know that this links to a
file on the same computer on the same
server as
the current file that i'm viewing but
it's in a sub
directory it's in the article
subdirectory and this is going to
actually work whether we have a relative
or an absolute reference but here
i'm doing it with a relative reference
so
one question that comes up is do i want
to use an absolute reference or a
relative reference
and here's the thing if if i want to
link to another web server so here i'm
trying to link to an article on the new
york times
server that actually needs to be done
with an absolute reference there's no
way to have a relative reference from
one server to another so right there
that's one clear distinction
so i can do everything i want with
absolute references why would i ever
want to use a relative reference
well it turns out that there's actually
a bunch of big benefits to using
relative references
so one of the benefits of having
is that they're much more portable
and so what i mean by this is if i have
a website
and all the references between the
different web pages on the website are
using
relative references i can take all those
files and those folders and move them to
another computer
so here's an example of why that might
be useful
so a while back carnegie mellon was
having financial difficulties actually
all the universities were um
i think this was at the 2008 stock
market crash
and they ended up letting all their
lecturers go
now suppose the same thing happened to
stanford
and i had a great website that was
sitting on the stanford servers
and i had all these different files and
they were all linked together
and i ended up having to go to harvard
because stanford was
out of money and let me go well if i
have absolute references
in this website and i take it to harvard
which is
pretty standard practice uh universities
will
typically let you take your material
with you so i i take my material i take
it to harvard
and you know if i'm using absolute
references in my material that means
every time i have a link from one web
page to another web page within my
website it says
http web.stanford.edu and i'm going to
have to go in there
and erase the stanford and replace it
with harvard and you know i'm just going
to be bawling my eyes out because
you know harvard's good but it's not
stanford and so by using those absolute
references moving it from one server to
another i've completely broken every
single reference
in contrast if i'm using relative
references
every time i refer from one webpage to
another web page
it's not it doesn't have the full url it
doesn't have web.stanford.edu
it just says hey there's this other file
it's in the same folder or maybe it's in
a subfolder
but those links are all still working so
i can take my entire website i can move
it to the harvard server
and all the internal links are still
working i'm still pretty sad of course
but you know at least i don't have to go
in and delete all the
references to stanford and replace them
at
another advantage of relative references
is relative references are shorter
that's nice from a typing standpoint you
don't have to type http
colon slash slash name of server slash
um it's also going to be a bit cheaper
and this can add up over time because
you're serving up fewer bits right those
extra bits for the http
and the name of the server those aren't
in the files
your your html files are just a tad bit
shorter
they're you're gonna pay a bit less
money for your bandwidth and um
you know it'll be slightly faster it's
nice it's not it's not a huge win
but it is a win and there's no cost so
it's all win all right so generally
there's
a lot of advantages to using relative
references the main reason why we
use an absolute references as we just
saw if you're trying to link to another
web server
like if i've got a link from my stanford
website to the new york times
dot com website well i don't really have
any choice i can't create a relative
reference from one server to another
relative references only work within a
server so
use an absolute reference then
okay you may notice a a fair number of
urls where they don't actually specify
the file name
so www.stanford.edu you know that says
it's on the www.stanford server it
doesn't say what the file is
and you know you could go to w this this
isn't actually a
real url so don't try this one of five
students there's actually a couple more
subdirectories but
um i thought i'd shorten it to keep the
example simple
uh www.stanford.edu cs105
um it's not specifying the name of a
file
and so all web servers have a particular
default file that they're going to serve
up most
servers use the file index.html so
there's a file in the directory called
index.html and somebody does not specify
a file name they specify folder name but
they don't specify file name
the index.html is going to get served up
so that's sort of your default name
there are some other names used for this
but index.html is the most common you
may also see it
a web server some use home.html
or some of them use and then in fact
some of them
actually don't use html they just use
dot htm
you can actually blame microsoft for
this
way back in the day all files on
microsoft systems
had to be named but what was called 8.38
letters
and three letters after the dot i just
it's pretty shocking to me that seems
super limited having only eight
characters but
that's the way it was but hey it's all
good
bill gates seems to be doing good stuff
plus
the building that i can't go to anymore
is named after him because they've
donated much money to it for that too
but
um yeah happy thoughts to bill
for his work on the uh
uh philanthropy for for medical purposes
good job dylan melinda okay
now this thing that we've been typing
here http
stanford.edu another.html
this is what's referred to as a url or a
uniform resource locator
it turns out that there's a second
version of this
where instead of using http you use
https this is a secure version of http
we'll be talking about it in much more
detail on exactly what it's all about
when we spend our week talking about
computer security a little bit later on
down the line it turns out that
our url uniform resource locator is
actually a subset of a much bigger
standard called uri
for uniform resource identifier
and there's a whole bunch of uris and
some of these are actually
kind of handy um probably the handiest
of them is the mailto
uri and you can use this to create a
link on your web page where
somebody clicks on the link and they
mail a message to you
um this does assume that the web browser
is set up to use mail
[Music]
and you could specify in addition to
specifying the address to send it to you
can specify other things like the
subject
you can cc some people you can put a
body on there
i do want to caution you um
be careful about putting email addresses
up on
the internet you will notice that our
and by r i mean none of the cs105 or
cs106e teaching staff
addresses are up there and that's
actually because there are programs that
surf the web looking for email addresses
and put them on spamless
it's too late for me i get a ton of spam
although since the computer science
department moves this to
google's g suite google seems to have
taken care of most of it they also
occasionally
take real emails sent by students and
dump it in the spam folder so that
part's not so good but
they mostly got rid of all the spam i
get i used to get a ton of spam all the
time
and occasionally i get in lists where i
would get spam messages like
every five minutes it was just freaking
horrible anyway so if you put your email
address on web pages and it's clearly
obviously an
email address these programs will grab
them and stuff you on spam lists so be
super cautious on there
but you know if your business uh
you know maybe it's worth it for you to
have it
super convenient for people to email uh
an
address an email address associated with
companies you're just going to go ahead
and stick that up there
and using this mailto uri you can make
it really easy for somebody to email you
um there's a bunch of other types of uri
so there's a ftp it's cure ftp
there's facetime so you click on a link
it starts at facetime and you click on
the link
start at sub skype um gamers there's
even one that starts up steam
so there's all sorts of different uris
up there
one of the uris that you may see is this
file uri and in fact
if you're loading a file into the web
browser and that file is on your current
computer this is
basically what you're going to see so
file colon slash slash and then the c
colon that's that's windows for the
current uh
domain main hard disk
this works when it's on your computer
but
don't use it um
it's specific to a specific location on
your computer
it's completely not portable so we
talked about how relative links are
portable
this is completely not portable and one
of the things that it being completely
not portable
it's going to cause you problems is when
you take your files you zip them up and
submit them
for your homework assignments and
the ta unzips them on their computer
those files are no longer on those files
are no longer in the same location as
they were when you zip them up and so
this is going to completely break all
your stuff
for grading purposes so you know
generally don't use it it's a bad idea
and it's especially a bad idea for our
class because you'll lose points for
grading
that's it for this video in the next
video we're going to take a look at how
to style our
links uh changing the colors and
changing the appearance of them
i'll see you then